Here are 5 cool experiments, you can try at
home, part 1.
Look what you can do with a bit of water,
and an empty glass bottle. If we put this
in the microwave on high power for 1 minute
and 30 seconds, the water starts vaporizing
into steam. And of course that means the bottle’s
going to get really really hot. So before
we touch it, we’ll need some insulated oven
mitts. Now what do you think will happen if
we turn the bottle upside, down and dip it
in a bath of cold water? The water gets sucked
up with a tremendous amount of force. Which,
apparently can fill the bottle in less than
a second. This works because steam takes up
a lot more space than water, so when it rapidly
contracts inside the bottle, the outside air
pressure forces the water in to fill the void,
until the pressures equalize. Did you know
you can turn a stack of pennies into a battery,
that will light LEDs and power a calculator?
If we use sand paper to shave off one side
of the pennies, we end up with bi-metallic
discs that are copper on one side, and zinc
on the other. Try stacking the pennies 10
high so they’re all facing the same direction,
then place pieces of cardboard, soaked in
vinegar, between each coin. This makes an
improvised 6 volt battery with just enough
power to light a couple of LEDs. The copper
top is the positive, the zinc is the negative,
and surprisingly, 3 pennies is all it takes
to power a small calculator like this. That’s
the power in your pocket change. This slick
little trick is good to know, if “urine”
trouble. It might sound weird, but there is
a way you can start a fire with your pee.
Pour some of the yellow liquid into a clear
plastic bag or plastic wrap, then collect
the corners together and twist it around until
it bulges out to form a liquid sphere. Now
you can focus the sunlight, and start burning
dark paper or fine tinder just like you would
with a magnifying glass. Nurse the embers
into a flame with the help of some kindling,
and you’ve just started a fire with your
pee. Did you know you can turn a hunk of butter,
into a candle? Start by cutting a block of
butter in half, then roll up a bit of tissue
paper to make an improvised wick. Push the
wick into the butter and light it, and incredibly,
the butter burns just like a candle. Each
half gives up to 4 hours of light, so try
it for yourself and see if anyone else finds
your experiment, enlightening. If you promise
to be careful, you can make a mini pyrotechnic
display with some cheap disposable lighters.
By hacking into the valve tensioner, and adjusting
it counter-clockwise 2-3 times, we can get
it to shoot a flame up to 12 inches long!
It’s a micro handheld flamethrower that
shoots clean-burning gas. Just don’t run
it very long or it might catch the casing
on fire and blow up. You can also try wrapping
the spring around the flint to make a tiny
flint bomb. Hold it in an open flame until
it starts glowing red-hot, then throw it on
the concrete, far away from anything that
could catch on fire.  Well there are 5 cool
experiments you can try at home. Just make
sure to use common sense and try not to get
anyone hurt in the process. That’s it for
now. If you liked these experiments, perhaps
you’ll like some of my others. Check them
out at www.thekingofrandom.com
I saved the best project for last. Hey guys.
One of the best projects you can invest in,
is yourself. And you’ll get the best results
by using the best tools. This week I’ve
been reading this book called the success
principles by Jack Canfield, and it’s basically
an instruction book that will show you step
by step, how to map out where you are in life,
to where you want to be, and show you how
to make it happen. And because you’re supporting
my videos, Audible.com has sponsored me once
again, which means I get to give you the audiobook
of your choice, free of charge. On their website
it’s normally $23 to download, but if you
go through my link in the description, and
sign up for their 30 day free trial, you can
get this book today for no cost. Now if you
don’t feel this recommendation was right
for you, they have 150,000 other audiobooks
you can choose from, or trade for, with no
questions asked. You can also cancel anytime
with no obligation. So if you want to grow
a popular YouTube channel, or start a successful
business, or even just ask that cute girl
out on a date, this book will give you the
power to make that happen. And I really believe
that because these are principles I’m experimenting
with all the time. Thank you for supporting
my videos, and I’ll see you in the next
one. Bye.